E aí
[Música]
a de Álvaro de Campos
o aniversário
e no tempo em que festejavam o dia dos
meus anos
e eu era feliz e ninguém estava morto
e na casa antiga até eu fazer anos era
uma tradição de há séculos
Oi e a alegria de todos EA minha estava
certa com uma religião qualquer
e no tempo em que festejavam o dia dos
meus anos eu tinha a grande saúde de não
perceber coisa nenhuma ser inteligente
para entre a família
e não ter as esperanças que os outros
tinham de mim quando vim a ter
esperanças já não sabia ter esperanças
quando vinha olhar para a vida perderá o
sentido da vida
É sim o que fui de suposto mesmo o que
fui de coração e parentesco o que fui de
serões de 6 província O que foi de
amar-me e o ser menino o que fui ai meu
Deus o que são hoje sei que fui
é A que distância
e nem eu acho
e o tempo em que festejavam o dia dos
meus anos
é o que eu sou hoje é como a umidade no
corredor do fim da casa pondo grelado
nas paredes
é o que eu sou hoje e a casa dos camarão
treme através das minhas lágrimas
é o que eu sou hoje e terem vendido a
casa é terem morrido todos é estar eu
sobrevivente a mim mesmo como um fósforo
frio
e no tempo em que festejavam o dia dos
meus anos que meu amor como uma pessoa
esse tempo desejo físico da alma de se
encontrar ali outra vez por uma viagem
metafísica e carnal com uma dualidade de
eu para mim
a comer o passado como pão de fome sem
tempo de manteiga nos dentes vejo tudo
outra vez com uma nitidez que me cega
para o que há aqui
a mesa posta com mais lugares com
melhores desenhos na loiça com mais
copos o aparador com muitas coisas doces
frutas o resto na sombra debaixo do
alçado as tias velhas os primos
diferentes
bom e tudo era por minha causa
e o tempo em que já vou o dia dos meus
anos para meu coração não penses deixa
eu pensar na cabeça ó meu Deus meu Deus
meu Deus
e hoje já não faço anos e
é duro
é só não se dias sem velho quando for
mais nada
a raiva de não ter trazido o passado
roubado na algibeira
e o tempo em que festejavam o dia dos
meus anos
Oi bom dia a todos
é muito obrigada pelo convite é uma
enorme honra e gosto partilhar este
momento de poesia com todos vós o
segundo poema que eu vou ler
a cruzar-me com ele esta semana quando
preparava esta função
E aí
Esse é um poema de Ana Luísa Amaral a
e tecnologistas
E aí
é a minha filha perguntou-me o que era
para a vida inteira
e eu disse que era para sempre
e naturalmente
é mas também os conceitos de infinito
são diferentes
e o que ela perguntou depois
e o que era para sempre
E eu não podia falar em Universos
paralelos em conjugações e disjunções de
espaço e tempo nem sequer em morte
a vida inteira É até morrer
é mas eu sabia ser inevitável ela que
estão seguinte
e o que é morrer
e por isso respondi aqui para sempre era
assim Largo Abrir muitos braços seria
com o jogo que ficará meio
é o fim do jogo todo
e disse-me que amanhã
eu queria estar comigo para a vida
inteira
E aí
[Música]